sage steel's an espn anchor she's the
latest end up in front of the
cancellation firing squad this is from
fox news it says espn's sportscenter
host sage steele
is being pulled off the air following a
remark she made knocking her employer's
vaccine mandate
as well as comments made about former
president obama i think we have we have
the vaccine comments here uh let's let's
play those first this is on a podcast
and this is what she said about uh
vaccine mandates
i i think to man i respect everyone's
decision i really do but to mandate it
is um
sick
and it's scary to me in many ways um but
i
have a job
a job that i love and frankly a job that
i need but again i love it i just um i'm
not surprised it got to this point
especially with disney i mean a global
company yes
so that's what she said now the
headlines are telling you that sage
steel is uh came out as an anti-vaxxer
she came out against vaccines
none of that happened obviously
this is the sleight of hand trick that
that of course we've seen from the left
on this issue just like on every issue
there's always some kind of trick and
that's what it is on this if you're
against vaccine mandates that means that
you're that you're against vaccines in
general
and then about barack obama she says um
talking about
filling out the u.s census form and she
expressed wanting to include multiple
races instead of just one she says if
they make you choose a race um
what are you going to put and i go both
and she's like well you can't
talk about filling out a census form
she goes barack obama chose black and
he's biracial and i'm like
congratulations to the president that's
his thing
i think that's fascinating considering
his black dad was nowhere to be found
and his white mom and grandma raised him
but hey you do you i'm gonna do me
okay all right once
right that's deeply controversial there
just pointing out a fact
that barack obama was
is
biracial he was raised by his white
mother and grandparents
but didn't identify with that side of
him at all identified as black that's
true
uh but that's why that's why she was
pulled off the air now espn
has
explaining its move it says at espn
we embrace different points of view
they just pulled off one of their one of
their star one of their main anchors for
expressing her point of view
they pulled her off air for that but
they're only doing it because they
embrace this is their this is their way
of embracing
uh different points of view we embrace
different points of view dialogue and
discussion make this place great
that said we expect that those points of
view be expressed respectfully in a
manner consistent with our values and in
line with our internal policies we're
having direct conversations with sage
and those conversations will remain
private
so you can have different points of view
as long as those points of view are in
keeping with
our values with the left's values
which which is another way of saying
that you can't have different points of
view at all
so this is this is
really important to understand she's
pulled off the air and this isn't even
there's no indication that she's a
republican or a conservative god forbid
uh there's not even any indication of
that i have no idea what our politics
are
i would assume i don't know this i would
assume that she at least leans heavily
liberal only because i don't know how
you would survive for this long at espn
if you didn't
um
but nothing that she said
taking the obama stuff out of it because
that's nothing at all there
with the vaccine
there's there's no reason why that has
to be a conservative right-wing talking
point
though as a conservative right-winger
i'm happy to take it
i mean if you want to insist
that um
you know standing up in favor of choice
when it comes to the drugs you put in
your body that's now a conservative
point of view
fine i mean i'll i'll take that
but even as a conservative i don't see
any reason why it needs to be
that's what we hear from the left anyway
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated